[Music]
hey what's going on everybody its Sean
Evans who first we feast comin at you
from Jimmy's 43 in the East Village
where I'm experiencing PTSD because last
time I was here I paid the spicy iron
price with my buddy chili Klaus these
are the Carolina Reapers yes well we're
not gonna be eating reapers today but we
will be bringing the heat as we explore
the ever-growing world of spicy pepper
infused beer
we have Katerina Martinez from lineup
Brewing who's brought along some of the
most popular most talked-about spicy
beers on the market and you know what
that cue means it's time to figure out
what the hell we're gonna be drinking
today it's pretty difficult to make
well-balanced spicy beer first of all
there's a huge range of pepper that you
can put into beer so anywhere from a hop
in the arrow to like a chipotle pepper
they're gonna give you different flavors
some breweries are probably like you
know let's make this the hottest beer
they've ever had they have one and they
move on to something else
for me I wanted to accentuate the other
characteristics within the malt because
I want people to drink more than one of
them I think that I will always prefer a
chipotle pepper if I'm making a dark
beer if I'm making a light beer like an
IPA I would absolutely move towards a
habanero that's where they get
significantly hotter though alright so
at the table now we have Katerina we
have our palate cleansers and we have
our five pack of beers here this is
Pachamama porter and it's a
collaboration between two roads and evil
twin
[Music]
that was going to happen all right so
this is yeah Cheers
I think that you really get it in the
way that the beer smells this has a nice
chipotle smoky character I really like
this I feel like I could have multiple
of these this is gel this is nothing
this is no big deal territory any before
we move on clean up habanero sculpin by
ballast point this is probably one of
the more commonly known spicy beers see
this I feel like is kind of opposite of
the porter and it has really sort of a
profound habanero taste to it absolutely
you do get hit with the hot character at
first and then you get that lingering
burden that comes afterwards and it's
pretty hot you would have to be crazy to
drink a six-pack of this but I would
respect it you'd have to be chilly close
rogue which is a big brewery it's an
organ one of the things are known for is
making very bold here so this is
definitely straight up their alley
I get that sort of like little sriracha
burned right right I throw it a little
bit but then on top of that I have so
many other elements and I don't know
what's up what's down what's left what's
right and I'm just kind of good
I'm actually very much enjoying the
complexity of this but there's no way I
could finish you know I can't drink a
bottle like this and I don't know who
great
I know pipe works this is right up my
alley honestly this has ancho chilies in
it and it's an Imperial milk stout
barrel-aged it's gonna be probably very
mini enriched
[Music]
Wow oh gosh yeah the alcohol on this is
13% so this is like basically have like
a barley wine that's thick as hell with
some cinnamon and an ancho chiles this
is delicious
very good very good [ __ ] you up to this
is guzzle gone wild and it's by
Stillwater artisanal a Goza is kind of a
sour funky beer this one in particular
has mango lemongrass Thai Chili's and
sea salt it has a little bit of that
acidic sourness to it for sure but I'm
not really getting the Thai Chili's that
are like smacking me in the face you
know what I mean like this is very much
like sort of almost like a sports drink
like I could play pick-up basketball and
drink this and be fine
alright so I'm gonna break these down
then I'm gonna crown a king why cuz it's
my show what are you gonna do about it
alright so for the porter for me good
beer but just not enough of a real like
spice pepper situation for me to
recommend it to the chili heads out
there
sriracha rogue it's not my it's not my
cup of tea alright am i it's not my
favorite it's not my walk on the beach
it's a whole smoothie it's a whole lunch
dinner smoothie for you alright then
this last one the Gosa it is weird it's
strange its salad but likewise you know
there's Thai chilies in this but I
wasn't getting really a sort of a Thai
meal chili situation if I'm gonna
recommend a spicy beer a chili beer a
pepper driven beer I need to really
taste that pepper when I go for
pipeworks I get a little bit of a tingle
I get some spice I get some heat but I
get more cinnamon okay now with Ballas
point that is straight habanero they
call themselves a habanero beer and they
are a habanero beer like all the way
through the spice the heat the taste it
just smacks you right in the face so if
you want as advertised you got to go
here you got to go with the habanero you
got to go with ballast point runaway
favorite for me nobody pays me nobody
writes me any checks nobody wants me to
endorse their products but [ __ ] it I'll
do it for free ballast I'm like a little
shocked you turned on your hometown of
Chicago did to pick San Diego man and
this is like a big brand or if you got
it you got it you got it
[Music]